With ultraviolet blood irradiation therapy be useful in preventing the
testicists or other anti-cancer benefits if so is this procedure that is
usually prescribed by MDs? So no, it's not usually prescribed by any oncologists
it's more of an alternative therapy. I personally don't know any clinics in the
Midwest that do this therapy. Yeah you'd have to look around that do it. Is it
beneficial that can be? I mean there can be benefit to it. But again you're
radiating the blood or you're osodating the blood. You're just taking it out you
have a portal in one arm and another in another and it splits your
machine and it's going right through your body like that. That's how that machine
works. To me that makes more sense for pathogen therapy like
Lyme disease and things that it does so for cancer. But I know that there are the
doctors that do have the machines are doing it for cancer too. So you'll have to
look into that. I don't do that so.